foreign
about 1600 years ago Saint Augustine
wrote the confessions which was the
story of his youthful descent into sin
and his later conversion to Christianity
and book two of the confessions has a
great beginning
I propose now to set down my past
wickedness and carnal Corruption of my
soul so you expect sex
but to the disappointment of readers
over the centuries the sin that
Augustine talks about doesn't isn't
carnal at all it has to do with pairs
he and his friends break into an orchard
and they steal some Pairs and that was
it they didn't have anything against the
person who owned the orchard they
weren't hungry they threw the pears to
pigs what stunned Augustine and
Disturbed him was that he seemed to be
motivated by a desire just to do wrong
he writes if any part of one of those
pairs passed my lips it was a sin that
gave it flavor I had no motivation for
wickedness except wickedness itself
I was foul and I loved it
now I'm a psychologist and I was
interested in real life stories of
perverse action so I started the
perversity project where I invited
people to send me stories about perverse
things that they did I defined these
access when you choose to do something
you know is wrong morally or otherwise
at least in part because it's wrong
so one of the first stories I got was
flirted with a woman's boyfriend knowing
fully well he liked me I knew I could
steal him if I wanted but I didn't want
to do that I just wanted her to feel
uncomfortable whenever the three of us
were in the same room
causing people pain is wrong but that's
exactly why I did it and in fact this is
the the plot of the Dolly Parton song
Jolene
um sometimes it's self-destructive a
young man wrote to me ice skating on a
pond dark and Frozen spot 30 yards out
instead of avoiding it I skate towards
it knowing but wondering knowing but
wondering and splash
now psychologists have long been
interested in these sort of violent
disruptive perverse acts and the kinds
of people who do them an example people
often get give is a Joker from the
Batman comics
um and Christopher Nolan's filmed a dark
knight uh Alfred Batman's butler
describes the Joker by saying some men
can't be bought bullied recent or
negotiated with some men just want to
watch the world burn
and psychologists have thought up a need
for chaos scale that event that gives
you a bunch of statements and how much
you agree with them will tell you how
much you want to watch the world burn so
just do this quietly in your head
I need chaos around me it's too boring
if nothing is going on
sometimes I just like destroying
beautiful things
but not all the stories I got had that
kind of nature some were a little bit
more of benign here's one of my
favorites
on one occasion in my early 20s I was
out with a friend he decided to get
himself an ice cream
and before he had a chance to try it I
stuck my finger in it
I tried to play it off as a joke
but really I had the sudden thought man
it would be messed up if I just jammed
my finger in his ice cream someone else
wrote me when I was in a professional
choir at every concert I felt the desire
to sing a few notes very incorrectly on
purpose to this day I don't completely
understand why someone else wrote me and
this is going to sweetest sadness little
example of modest perversity
sometimes I walk on the grass instead of
the path just because I know it's wrong
now a lot of perversity makes the world
worse I wouldn't want an Uber driver who
scores high on a need for chaos scale
and I don't want a friend or a colleague
either but sometimes I'll suggest to you
perversity can be clever creative
beautiful and there's some examples from
art
there was an illustrious art exhibition
in New York City in 1917 and he said you
can send in anything you want we'll
accept everything so Marcel Duchamp sent
in a urinal not to describe the founder
and they rejected it they said no no we
just accept artwork but Duchamp insisted
it was artwork and the resulting
controversy turned out to be one of the
pivotal moments in in the history of
Modern Art
or take Banksy a few years ago um Banksy
sold a painting girl with balloon at
Sotheby's at auction and he set up the
frame that the moment the painting was
sold the moment the gavel went boom a
machine in the frame shredded the
painting halfway through horrifying the
audience but um and but but getting on
the front page of the newspapers all
over the world later on describing a
Banksy quotes a Russian Anarchist who
says the urge to destroy is also a
creative urge
or take comedy perversity is part and
parcel of Comedy so much of what's funny
is when people do things that are
irrational or involved in the right
hands perversity is such a source of joy
perversity can also be powerful Rory
Sutherland wrote irrational people are
much more powerful than rational people
he gave two reasons why this is so
the first is their threats are so much
more convincing suppose I'm in a
confrontation with you and you threaten
me and you're irrational reasonable
you're a rational reasonable person so I
know your threats
well I know your threats are going to be
normal and proportional and but if
somebody is hinting here you're a
perverse agent I have no idea what
you're capable of and you're far more
frightening to me
second reason is if you're holy
predictable people learn to hack you so
again if you're rational and I have to
outsmart you figure out what you're
going to do next I'll get you'll do the
rational thing if you're perverse you're
harder to predict and so harder to hack
Edgar Allan Poe describing perversity
described it talk about imps little
magical demons in our heads that cause
us to do terrible things but like I said
I'm a psychologist I don't believe in
imps I think what we do has reasons has
motivations and I think for perverse
actions there's a range of them
um one of them was mentioned by
Augustine so later on after describing
the incident of despairs he writes I
would not have done it by myself
my satisfaction not lying to pairs that
lay in the crime itself committed in a
league with a gang of sinners it's a
social Force drove him and there are
other things too one force that really
interests me goes under many names
self-governance Freedom Liberty agency
called it autonomy call it a desire to
to to be free to do what you want free
of the constraints of other people and
free also of the constraints of
rationality and morality and Jonah
Berger gives a nice example of this he
talks about the tide pod challenge of a
few years ago where many teenagers
instead of using these as detergent
products bit into them and sometimes
consume them now as you might imagine uh
Procter and Gamble who own the products
were incredibly unhappy about this and
they set up an extremely expensive ad
campaign designed to stop people from
consuming these products and one of your
campaigns involved the football player
popular football player known as Gronk
so the the ad would begin hey Gronk is
eating the pods ever a good idea
and Gronk responds no no no no
Burger points that when this ad came up
consumption of the pots shot up
no I doubt it nobody's gonna tell me
what who is this Gronk telling me what
to do I'm going to be an autonomous free
being and psychologists call this
reactants
and this is means it's an unpleasant
feeling that emerges when people
experience a threat to our loss of their
free behaviors and there's a wealth of
laboratory studies looking at reactants
so so they test the idea that what you
try to do is re-establish the threat and
freedom and so one of the studies for
instance looks at binge drinking ads and
finds that when binge drinking ads are
particularly heavy-handed people often
respond by drinking more
no one's got I want to re-establish my
freedom I want to do what I want
um or take threats of reprisal there's a
lovely study by a team of political
scientists which asked you asked the
subjects to imagine that they're an
ambassador to a country and they're
deciding whether or not to have
sanctions towards that country
in one condition the dictator says if
you do sanctions towards our country
that's okay I won't do anything in the
second condition the dictator says if
you do sanctions towards our country I
will unleash terrorist attacks against
you
what's the stunning finding from us is
that in the second condition not the
first they were more likely to do it a
lot of our perverse actions are a
response to people telling us not to do
what we want to do and it makes us want
Ola more to do that thing
I think there are two lessons from the
study of perversity one is to appreciate
its role in everyday life
it's really worth knowing that there are
people out there who really do want to
watch the world burn
and I think it's also worth knowing that
each and every one of us at some point
in our life wants to watch the world
burn at least a little bit
I think it's worth knowing
at least for for consequential decisions
like choosing who to vote for that
people aren't just motivated by material
self-interest or or by an affiliation or
social and political group sometimes
people want to be autonomous beings they
want to be free and telling these people
what you're doing is stupid what you're
doing is irrational uh what you're doing
is immoral
can have the paradoxical effect of
motivating them to do exactly what you
don't want them to do
the second lesson of perversity has to
do with our everyday lives a lot of
perversity is awful I think the world
will be better off without it but I
think we've seen a little bit that
perversity could be funny
it could be clever I I think I think I
think it can make the world a better
place and um and so I guess I'd suggest
that a life with a little bit of
perversity in it a life where sometimes
you put your finger into your friend's
ice cream it's a life that's a lot more
interesting
thank you
foreign